say about that I feel like you've kind
of got more of a guy's brain when it
comes to these kind of things like
you're more logic based like okay
um some have a problem well in this in
this sense
I feel like in this instance you're
seeing it from my point of view that
like okay there's a problem what's the
solution I don't want to just carry on
moaning about it what's where's I feel
like you know not all not at all but I
think a lot of women will kind of prefer
to just kind of complain you know what
I'm saying and just talk and talk I want
to talk about it it doesn't I don't care
about the solution I just want to talk
about it kind of thing and I've heard
many women like even my own mum she's
like that she would just want to talk
about the problem over and over and
bring it up again like you know I mean
instead of okay let's fix this so I
think in that in that respect I think
you you've got more of like a kind of um
logical minders yeah let's get this over